tard dans la soirée alors sur le terrain
si je puis dire venons en maintenant à
l'évolution de la situation en rda
d'abord l'actualité du week-end c'est la
manifestation de 20 mille opposants au
régime dans les rues de leipzig à
l'appel de nouveaux forums pour réclamer
des élections libres et aussi la fin du
monopole du pouvoir du parti communiste
moins de monde que prévu mais il est
vrai que 4 millions d stalmans et c'est
l'autre évènement de ce week end sont
encore passés à l'ouest depuis hier
l'ambiance pourtant à changer
encombrement pollution problèmes de taux
de change il y a maintenant quelques
signes d'énervement dans la population
de berlin ouest où nous allons rejoindre
immédiatement
mémona hintermann
nous sommes ici sur le ku'damm qui est
l'équivalent des champs-elysées et de
berlin et comme vous le constatez noire
de monde ici et c'est toujours l'aspect
comme la scène derrière une chose a
disparu selon moi c'est l'émotion en
tout cas du côté des berlinois de
l'ouest parce qu'entre-temps dix jours
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait des
problèmes qui commençait à émerger les
autorités craignent qu'il y ait un
marché noir des marchandises mais aussi
les allemands de l'est viennent casser
les tarifs pour le travail le maire de
berlin ouest a d'ailleurs demandé aux
autorités des deux états de mettre sur
pied un accord pour la convertibilité du
marc de l'allemagne de l'est se bat pour
avec niveau pratiquement ya ici un
poteau 12
ici les gens disent qu'ils ne veulent
pas que les populations de l'autre
allemagne soit des mendiants ils ne
veulent pas non plus financé pour leur
rêve de les voir dans ce reportage qui
faisait monter ce matin avec marc touya
riz afin que la fête éternel très belle
c'est beau c'est à dire et hiboux les
gens d'ici sont ville a leaké
accueillant aujourd'hui les allemands de
l'est
pour eux le père noël passe maintenant
darlas est une ville ouverte les
habitants qui ont fui son parti ce
week-end l'une des causes ce sont les
travaux elle pollue vie fois plus qu'une
voiture occidental or ici
l'environnement est une priorité nous
explique ce berlinois de l'ouest on nous
oblige à nous équiper pour ne pas
polluer c'est très cher et
d'impressionner
les grandes firmes ont fait un geste de
solidarité
solidarité un mot qui commence à agacer
ceux qui vivent petit monde certains ne
sont pas la vie de cet homme qui vit ici
en allemagne de l'ouest on a du travail
il y à des emplois de personne ne veut
alors si les gens de l'est viennent
pourquoi pas
l'afrique de l'ouest les attraits de la
consommation sont des mirages côte
d'argent
si on veut avoir ton style faudra
travailler là bas
quel modèle pour nous à l'est
il faut prendre ce qui est bon dans les
deux systèmes oui moitié moitié
c'est totalement minable quand on
échange on remarque de chez nous oui
vous nous donnez 5 nabeul ça c'est
dégoûtant ce n'est pas mal de gars côté
mechtras peut-on deux pas de capitalisme
on veut juste acheté ce qu'on veut
peu de gens que nous avons rencontrés
souhaite rester dix jours après
l'ouverture du mur le premier frisson de
la liberté aurait-il suffi à calmer une
partie des allemands de l'est si c'est
oui l'équipe de crainte pourrait marquer
un premier point